hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
bleeding heart greeny millennial and
opposite of domestic goddess domestic
demon like i just horn a specific part
of the airport i don't have a passport
so i can't get out and facebook can
obviously tell because they've been
serving me zeroco ads i mean look at
that branding it's catnip for
millennials so obviously i bought the
whole set i've tried them all and i
thought i'd review them because i think
it's a cool example of a well thought
out environmentally friendly system most
of the products are household products
but there are some beauty products in
there as well this isn't sponsored
xerico offered to send me products after
i've reached out to them about a
question but i wanted to try them out
over a longer period of time without too
much pressure so the concept is zeroco
is a household and personal care product
company that focuses on reducing
single-use plastic and i'm usually quite
skeptical when it comes to brands that
focus on reducing single-use plastic
part of this is because i'm used to
reviewing skin care and compared to
other sources of single-use plastic in
our lives skincare is really just not
that much it takes a while to finish up
most products but a lot of skincare
brands act like you're going to save the
world if you buy their serum another big
reason is that a lot of plastic free
brands make a lot of trade-offs that
don't really make a lot of sense they
aren't really well thought out and it
ends up being green washing for example
sometimes they switch to really heavy
glass containers that end up having a
huge carbon cost for transport and they
also break a lot in transport which
means you end up wasting a lot of
product sometimes brands switch to
bioplastics that might be compostable
but not truly biodegradable they can't
be recycled and most people don't
compost them properly so they might have
been better off just using recyclable
plastic some of these bioplastics also
have a bigger carbon footprint than
traditional plastics if you make them
using renewable energy and the final
reason is that most eco-friendly brands
are also really into that whole clean
beauty scientists are trying to kill you
thing i hate this sort of marketing i've
talked about why in my video clean
beauty is a scam and won't give us safer
products i don't really boycott this
because it's so hard to find brands that
have zero clean beauty fear-mongering in
their marketing a lot of the time it's
because the brand themselves are misled
and i try to be nice to people who are
doing the wrong thing out of good
intentions but i do get really annoyed
and if there's an alternative i'll take
it but zerocode drew household products
which is something we use a lot more of
so we have a lot more single-use
containers and australia is pretty bad
in terms of the amount of single-use
plastic per person zirco also have a lot
more dimension than just taking ocean
waste and turning it into bottles i
asked my two favorite sources for
environmental science questions what
they thought the ecowell and waste-free
phd and they both said it looked like a
pretty good idea xeroco is based on a
closed-loop refill system you buy their
products which come in refillable
pouches there's also optional forever
bottles which come in pretty millennial
friendly pastel colors i bought the
starter kit which has everything in it
you fill your dispensers with the
pouches once you collect 15 empty
pouches you send them back in the reply
paid mailing bag you need 15 to make the
carbon cost of mailing worth it zurich
then clean and refill the pouches for
the next person the dispensers are made
from ocean beach and landfill-bound
waste there's a tracking code on the
back so you can see where your bottles
have come from for example all of mine
have come from indonesia the pouches are
also made from plastic that would have
gone to landfill they can be reused over
and over and over for a very long time
according to xeroco when they've worn
down they're going to be used to make
something else which zeroco haven't
disclosed yet as well as being reusable
these pouches are a lot lighter than
traditional bottles and so that saves
the carbon emissions from transport
xerico has also recently introduced
carbon negative deliveries that means
that offsetting two kilograms of carbon
dioxide per one kilogram produced carbon
offsetting is a bit of a mixed bag a lot
of the time it's used as an excuse to
not actually reduce emissions but i
don't think that's what's actually
happening here i think it's just meant
to be a nice bonus i'm sure it's not
really a perfect system i don't think
using products is ever going to be not
using products at all but i prefer not
to live in filth and this seems to be a
lot better thought out than a lot of
systems i've seen and it covers a lot
more bases ziriko also asks for
suggestions if you work in the
environmental space for how they can
improve so that's also quite nice on top
of being pretty damn thorough the things
that really sold me on xeroco were
firstly they're super convenient and
customer friendly they have all the
products i normally use and more getting
everything from the one place is a lot
more convenient and also has a smaller
impact than say getting laundry
detergent from one place and dishwashing
tablets from another it is mail order
only though and the 15 pouch system
might be a bit of an issue if you're
running low on one thing before you run
out of something else but they are
looking into getting their products into
stores soon there are tons of clear
instructions and answers to questions
they have a super comprehensive website
they have videos on rolling out the
refill pouches they have tips on things
like removing the tamper rings before
refilling your bottles which as an
overthinker i really appreciate they've
also been really responsive to questions
through their chat and through their
social media the second big point is
that their products actually sound
really good my biggest worry whenever i
switch to an eco-friendly brand is that
i don't end up liking the product so i
don't re-buy them that means that i
don't end up reusing the reusable
containers and because the reusable
containers are usually much heavier and
more robust than regular containers i
end up having a bigger impact on the
environment than if i just use my normal
products and that's even worse if the
product is so bad i don't end up using
it all up the handy thing about xeroco
is that they have hundreds of reviews
from customers on their website
everything is overwhelmingly positive
and you can see everyone's experiences
with the products on top of that they
sent a lot of their cleaning products to
independent testing labs for the sorts
of comparisons you see from consumer
advocacy groups like choice all of the
ones with published results performed
really well for example you can see
their laundry detergent once here they
also have convenient price comparisons
with supermarket brands on their website
i think sometimes they've chosen their
comparisons very carefully but it isn't
like they're comparing it only to really
expensive products obviously
supermarkets have regular sales so it's
not like you're buying everything at
full price but i think a lot of people
including me are happy to pay a little
bit more if it's better for the
environment they also have price
breakdown so you can see their pricing
structure and their profit margins which
is pretty neat number three is
ingredient transparency i talked about
how i'm allergic to mi and mci on
instagram these are two preservatives
that are commonly found in detergent and
shampoo and about 1.5 percent of the
population is allergic to them
unfortunately a lot of laundry
detergents don't list out their
ingredients like a cosmetic product and
they don't even list out their
preservatives like drug products in
australia do i think we hear a lot about
how unregulated beauty products are but
we get a lot more information about them
than we do about household products so
i've had a lot of instances where i'll
try out a laundry detergent and then
i'll get itchy and it took me a really
long time to narrow it down to mi and
mci i'm still not 100 sure because it's
so hard to track down these ingredients
zirico have ingredients list for all of
their products so it's really easy to
look for allergens i think the only
thing that's missing is the vague
solubilizer on the air freshener but you
never really see ingredients list for
air fresheners anyway and they don't
really get on your skin so this is
already infinitely great number four is
limited ingredient fear-mongering claims
i was actually expecting the worst from
them because they're from byron bay and
that is like the anti-vax capital of
australia this is a super frustrating
topic for me and other scientists a lot
of the time eco-friendliness goes
hand-in-hand with fear-mongering claims
about ingredients that make no sense if
you understand the basic principles of
toxicology and that makes me lose
confidence in whether or not they're
actually being environmentally friendly
whether or not that is actually based on
science and it isn't just screenwashing
i was pleasantly surprised by the amount
of fear-mongering there is a little bit
but it's not too loud and it's near the
bottom of the page so you actually have
to scroll to get to it they have this
most insert product name that you buy
from the supermarket contain harmful
chemicals that aren't great for you your
family or the planet which is like eye
roll they do say no nasties but they
don't go deep into the pseudoscience of
how particular ingredients are bad for
you which is nice i prefer if they
didn't have this at all but again this
is some of the least fearmongering i've
seen from an eco-friendly brand they do
have this cringy moment where they say
no sulfates but they clearly have sodium
cocoa sulfate on their hand wash and
their body wash i mean there's nothing
wrong with sulfates but if you're going
to make that claim and fear monger about
cell phase you probably shouldn't have
cell phase in your products now on to
the product reviews i was genuinely
surprised by how much i like the
products i'm used to products from eco
brands being a bit lacking in the
performance department but these were
actually really great they smell really
nice they use a lot of essential oils as
their fragrances but it's still quite
light unfortunately there aren't
fragrance free options yet there's only
one option for each product but they're
working on that starting with the
laundry liquid this was the product i
was most worried about i'm allergic to a
lot of laundry liquids i've had to
change the sheets in the middle of the
night months because i was itching so
much i messaged them to ask if they
recommended their detergent for people
with sensitive skin they said they
didn't know but people with sensitive
skin had given it good reviews so i
really appreciated their honesty there
it smells nice it has a light scent it
works well there's no itchiness for me
the forever bottle has the measuring cup
lid and the pouring spout which is
standard in a lot of supermarket brands
but not in all eco brands which i really
appreciate it's really convenient i'm a
bit scared to use their stain remover
because it's one of the few products
they have that have mi and mci the main
thing i use stain removers for is my
reusable cotton pads and i really don't
want to get stuff i might be allergic to
in my eyes i did use it once on cotton
pads and it seemed to work pretty well
and i didn't really have any issues with
it but i'm still a little bit cautious
my biggest issue is there's no
instructions on the forever bottle for
this so i have to look at the pouch
every time i use it i guess it's fine if
you're going to stick with this for
years and years but so far i haven't
used it enough to be familiar with it
the multi-purpose cleaner and the
bathroom and shell cleaner i don't know
what to say about these they work as
well as my other products they smell
okay they still have that sort of punch
you in the nose smell that you get from
regular cleaners it's from the alcohol
which is their main cleaning ingredient
the bathroom cleaner also has lactic
acid which is pretty standard for
chlorine-free cleaners i use the
multi-purpose cleaner on most things
i've used it in my plastic bins i've
used it on my induction stovetop and my
wooden table and my stone bench top and
i haven't had any trouble with them it
works really well now the air freshener
is the one product that i didn't think i
needed like every other millennial in
australia i have the aesop post poo
drops which are essential oils that you
drop into the toilet after you do a poo
so i didn't really think i needed this
but i've ended up really liking it it's
a spray air freshener so it de-stinks
the whole room a lot faster you can also
use it in other rooms if someone lets
off a really bad thought this is the
other product that has mi in it so i
just try not to breathe it in i haven't
had any issues with it yet it smells
nice i've also been really liking their
dishwasher tablets these are optional
they have a starter kit without the
dishwashing tablets if you don't have a
dishwasher they come in a cardboard box
they're little tablets with the
dissolving wrappers these actually work
better than my normal dishwashing
tablets but they are a bit more
expensive in my dishwasher they didn't
leave any droplet marks on my glasses i
did see some people complain about that
but maybe my dishwasher just works
particularly well with these i am a
little worried about the cardboard box
because of those dissolving wrappers
moisture can get in really easily maybe
would have been better if it came as
like a bottle of powder the dishwashing
liquid is also decent it's not as good
as my normal brand which is morning
fresh i would have preferred this to
come with a pump top but i actually use
my pump bottle which i refill anyway the
toilet cleaner also comes in the same
sort of bottle so it's got like a disc
lid i would have preferred a pointy
nozzle that you can aim around the ball
of the toilet but it actually works
pretty decently the toilet cleaner uses
lactic acid which is pretty common in
bathroom products that are chlorine free
the body wash and the hand wash come in
these pump bottles which is really handy
they smell really nice they have a nice
fresh unisex scent i think it might be a
bit strong for some people again they've
said they're looking into fragrance free
versions but right now these are the
only versions available they work really
well they use sulfates sulfates are
great since i bought the box they've
also announced four new personal care
products as well they are a shampoo a
conditioner body lotion and a deodorant
i think this is really convenient
because then those can be shipped with
these as well and getting everything
from the one place is a good way of
saving on carbon emissions again that is
assuming these products work for you if
they don't work then it's not going to
be a good system i don't know what the
products are like yet they haven't been
launched unfortunately a few more of
these clean beauty claims have come in
with the personal care products they
claim to be free from silicones sls sles
edta dyes parabens phthalates tea dea
dimethicone formaldehyde and triclosan
it's a bit silly because the shampoo
uses sodium cocoa sulfate which is the
same thing as in the body wash and the
hand wash sodium coco sulfate is
actually about 50 sodium lauryl sulfate
sls laurel refers to the fatty acid in
the surfactant coconut oil has lauric
acid as the main fatty acid so sodium
coco sulfate is actually about 50 sodium
lauryl sulfate 16 sodium meristem
sulfate 10 percent sodium pumitol
sulfate and the rest is a bunch of
pretty similar sulfates overall they
look like pretty decent formulas the
conditioner doesn't have silicone so i
don't think it's something i would
regularly use i was actually surprised
that they didn't come out with bar
products maybe it was a bit too hard to
formulate them and put them into their
supply chain another eco brand ethic has
byproducts and they can save a lot on
carbon emissions if they work well one
bar is equal to three bottles of shampoo
and it really saves on that weight of
the water that would be there if you had
a liquid product i've tried out a few
ethique bars recently and atheke are one
of the least fearmongering eco brands so
check them out if you're interested
unfortunately again their conditioner
bar doesn't work for me because of the
lack of silicones i'm most excited about
the deodorant a lot of people have
complained to me that they want
aluminium in their deodorant so it's
antiperspirant but they can't find one
that doesn't have single-use plastic
this is a refillable roll-on
antiperspirant deodorant with aluminium
apparently this is a world first they
have an faq that explains their decision
to use aluminium really nicely and i
wish they did the same for their other
products so they could say something
like fyi we don't use these ingredients
but we don't actually think there's
anything wrong with them the body lotion
also looks pretty standard which is
actually a good sign it comes in a pump
bottle so that's an overview of a new
brand i've been trying that i think is
really promising in terms of how they
address being environmentally friendly
and there's a lot less green washing
than i usually expect they still have
some gimmicks in there to hook people in
but they've implemented some pretty
solid ideas they also successfully get
around a lot of pain points that i think
stop environmentally friendly brands
from having a larger impact they're
currently only available in australia i
do have a referral link down there you
get 10 off i get 20 off i rarely ever
use brand specific referral links but i
do really like this brand i genuinely
think this is a good idea zerocode do
have a lot of discount codes so that
might not actually be the best discount
code at time of buying thanks to jen of
the ecowell for helping me out she is my
go-to on sustainable beauty she has a
really great podcast where she
interviews experts and also waste free
phd laura who is great for things about
plastic you can also follow me on
instagram lab muffin beauty science and
check out my blog labmuffin.com for more
science behind beauty